before we start recording I I I brought
this up like with the the the um
political correctness the this whole
culture of of being really sensitive and
really careful and uh like it always
felt weird to me like in jagas and I'm
pretty sure that it was included in like
the Final Cuts of movies episodes right
if if I'm not mistaken where they're
throwing around the word [__] and like
here's here's a funny one it's the word
has never bothered me because I've gone
back to the day like I think people have
always asked me have you been bullied or
whatever or anything when you were
younger and I'm like no and I'm like if
you ask Preston Preston will tell you
I'm the biggest bully so words words
have never hurt me like that I'll even
say [__] but what the funny thing to
me was in Jackass 3 when we did the big
hand for me to bring bam towards me he
was walking in the office and he had his
breakfast burrito and he was walking in
and I was doing the uh the Foosball I
said to him in his voice to kind of get
his attention like we're just around
like hey what's up [__] and he goes oh
what's up you know so I it to Bam and
that was in the cut nope they blurred it
they beeped it okay like what are you
doing I'm like that's how I that's how I
lured bam into the hand and they're like
no no Paramount said no can't use the
[__] word whatever right and I'm like
I'm the one saying it you know what I
mean right you know realistically I I
think that I I I could argue and and I
really do believe that what's more
offensive is the actual politically
correct term little person because I
think that that is inherently belittling
you know to say like to say like little
person you know I've always said I don't
give a [__] how tall wean is there's
nothing little about he's [__] epic
you know like yeah yeah yeah yeah I get
it on that but here's here's another way
that I took it too and that I think the
general population sees it I did Kevin
and Bean one time too and like hey uh
are you cool with [__] or whatever and
I'm like yeah what what I'm like you're
a [__] dude whatever you
know they had two little people on and
they got very offended by that word that
Kevin being just kept saying it to get
under their skin and you know it's like
well if you let it if you let it get to
you it's going to get to you if you
don't let it get to you just go get
ready this is going to be
gnarly pretty
gnarly kind of gnarly are we ready
[Music]
yeah what's up
Denver women can paint their boobs and
show them on Instagram so I figure I
should be able to paint my dick and do
whatever I
want Make some noise for my brother wean
are you
ready wait let me inspect for crabs this
[Music]
time when my buddies lit that stuff
right away I knew
I [__]
[Music]
up I'm not doing this to hurt you Dad
you're going to hurt me you're going to
piss me off